ce pantalon c'est le pantalon quand tu
arrives et donc vraiment tout petit et
aujourd'hui ça donne ça voilà à chaque
fois qu'on le regarde on est on rigole
quand on est mort dorée avec les enfants
parce qu'on se dit comment elle est
arrivée aujourd'hui elle est grande
comme ça
les souvenirs à richard conserve tout il
y a cinq ans et yvelinoise accueille une
petite fille de deux ans aujourd'hui
encore présente au coeur du foyer
c'était son premier accueil comme
assistante familiale dans mon métier on
n'est pas tout seul c'est implique toute
la famille tout notre entourage aussi
familiale donc pour moi on est une
famille d'accueil est né dans un
contexte où ou mes frères photo on a
tous travaillé dans le milieu du social
et puis ma mère elle nous a transmis ce
ce dont deux femmes d'aller vers les
autres et ce don de soi cette vocation
elle la partage avec son mari lui aussi
assistant familial et l'a transmise à sa
fille elle samia 24 ans actuellement en
formation une formation total de 300
heures la formation dure deux ans
on y ait deux jours par mois donc c'est
pas énorme ça nous permet de nous
organiser pour la garde des enfants au
cas où ils sont pas scolarisés ça permet
aussi de pouvoir dialoguer avec d'autres
collègues échanger des idées échangées
le notre quotidien en sept ans aicha et
sa famille ont accueilli près de 20
jeunes des enfants mais aussi des
adolescents comme léa aujourd'hui
majeurs la jeune fille n'hésite pas à
revenir dans cette famille qui l'a reçu
un temps à la base j'étais venu en
accueil d'urgence et j'étais venu pour
une soirée
au final je suis resté à presque un mois
donc c'était m'ont accueilli comme leur
famille comme si je faisais déjà partie
de la famille en fait donc c'est ça qui
a fait que je reste et je pense aussi
aïcha et samia travail pour le sda fille
le service d'accueil familial du
département les yvelines peuvent
accueillir jusqu'à 1400 jeunes dans le
besoin
les assistants familiaux s'occupe
d'enfants de la naissance à leurs 21 ans
on peut très bien avoir des parents qui
nous disent mais j'en peux plus je ne
peux pas assurer la vie une vie correcte
à mes enfants donc en fait ils peuvent
une remise une somme de placement
volontaire par les parents la plupart du
temps ce sont les placements qui sont
les placements en fait fait sur une
décision du juge
selon les cas les parents conservent
leur autorité légale
aujourd'hui les yvelines compte près de
600 assistants familiaux